[Music]
you might think that you have already
seen some of the most beautiful places
in the world and pictures but you should
look at them from another angle take one
step back we have it from the sky or go
there at a different time and you'll see
what it looks like totally different
make sure you watch this video and tell
the end to see what Stonehenge really
looks like if you love traveling as much
as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you ten photos that will
change the way you see the world Cairo
seeing the pyramids of Egypt is a dream
come true for many people but when you
live in Cairo this is just something
that you see every day they are probably
so used to it but they don't even notice
it anymore Cairo is the capital of the
largest city in Egypt the metropolitan
area is also the largest in the Middle
East and the Arab world and it's amazing
to see the new world next to something
that was built thousands of years ago
the city was built around the Nile in
the 1910s it was meant to be a lush city
just like Egypt used to be one of the
richest and most powerful civilizations
in the world but many things changed
over the years as apartments and hotels
replaced the gardens and the houses now
one of the best places to visit is
actually Pizza Hut either you love pizza
or are not a normal human being you will
just love the view that you have from
the restaurant that's because you can
see the pyramids of Egypt when you look
through the window if you want to take a
closer look you can also be one of the
millions of people who visit the
pyramids every year it has been four
thousand years and the pyramids are
still more beautiful than ever
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it and be sure
to let us know what you think in the
comment section love to hear from you
see you there
kampung palanga a small village suddenly
became one of the must visit attractions
in indonesia when the government
invested 300 million dollars indonesian
rupiah or a little more than twenty-two
thousand American dollars all they had
to do was paint all the buildings to
make it much more colorful it only took
one month to paint more than two hundred
houses and the result was revealed in
April 2017 this is why camp uncle Andy
is now called the rainbow village slam
at Widodo is a teacher and also the man
who came up with this idea inspired by
other Asian cities who did the same
thing the local council committee
thought it would give them a chance to
attract more tourists to the area and
they were absolutely right that's
because the village that used to be
struggling is now trending on social
media when you first look at it you can
see that the buildings are simply
covered with colored stripes but when
you take a closer look you can see
pieces of art around every corner for
example there is a pair of wings on a
wall colorful flags flowing in the wind
a big worm who wants to eat the visitors
balloons that you can pretend to hold
and so much more that's a great reason
why you should take the time to visit
this village and it's also a great
opportunity for some awesome Instagram
pictures Great Wall of China you have
all heard about this wall before but we
don't think that you have seen every
part of it as it is more than 13,000
miles long it was built in the 3rd
century BC as a defense system on the
northern border of the country and don't
think that you can just go on a
spaceship to see it that's because
astronauts have already confirmed that
the Great Wall of China
is not visible from space it's made from
materials that make it difficult to
discern from space the only way you can
see it is from low orbit under a
specific set of weather and lighting
conditions this is why we think that
going to space is not the best
idea you can also simply visit the Great
Wall of China but don't think that it
will all be peaceful and relaxing that's
because an estimated 50 million tourists
visit the Great Wall every year you will
never be alone on this fall as you are
not the only one who had that idea
anyway it would be hard to see the whole
Great Wall of China during only one
visit this is unless you are one of
those two people who are the first to
walk what was left of the Great Wall of
China just look at the end of the wall
it's weird to think that we have never
seen this part before nordlingen when
you are walking in this small town in
Germany everything looks normal but take
a look at it from the sky and you will
notice something that is really unusual
the perfectly round shape is just too
pleasing to the eyes and we wonder who
had that crazy idea but it was actually
caused by Nature that's because the
little town was built in a crater a half
mile wide asteroid hit the earth about
15 million years ago you could still see
the crater millions of years after and
it looks like some people thought that
it would be a great idea to build a city
there but actually the town founders
didn't even know what was happening
there that's because people thought that
nordlingen was just built near a volcano
until the 60s most people now think that
the city's walls are built on the rim of
the crater but it is actually much wider
with a diameter of about 15 miles but
you can still say the whole town sits
entirely in that crater and it's also a
really nice place to go as it looks like
a modern medieval town you can find a
bell tower an old-fashioned water mill a
converted monastery Bavarian houses and
more that's why nordlingen is a member
of city slow which are described as town
still curious of the old times and it's
totally worth of visits the Mona Lisa
this is probably the most famous
painting in the world this is why most
people absolutely want to see it when
they go to France but don't think that
you're the only one he wants to see the
Mona Lisa at the Louvre Museum that's
because hundreds of people have the same
idea every day and you probably won't
get a chance to see it unless you wait
for a long time you'll also notice that
it's much smaller than you thought it
would be and
we'll be really hard to take a good
picture of it is it really worth it
you're the only one who can answer this
question the portrait was painted by
Leonardo da Vinci around 1503 most
people think that the woman in the
picture was Lisa Guerra Dini
wife of a Florentine cloth merchants
named Francesco del Giocondo this would
explain why the painting is also called
La Gioconda someone commissioned it but
the painter decided to take the portrait
to France instead so it could be part of
the French royal collection this is
probably why it is so popular nowadays
but what we love the most is that
intriguing smile people are still asking
themselves so many questions about that
painting but what they really want to
know is what this woman was thinking
when she was smiling in the picture
Copacabana if you are not ready to see
the Mona Lisa at the Louvre Museum you
might think that it's a good idea to
simply relax on the beach but this is
not what's going to happen if you ever
go to Copacabana
in Rio de Janeiro in Brazil that's
because too many people have that idea
and you'll sometimes feel like there is
not even enough air for everyone to
breathe in that crowd just look at what
happens when the Rolling Stones were
playing live at Rio de Janeiro it's not
like that all the time but it still
makes us want to visit a less popular
beach but this is not the only reason
why you should avoid this Beach that's
because Rio de Janeiro is not the safest
place to visit even though it's not the
worst place either there is poverty and
great well it can be savage and
sophisticated there is an old and the
new world and this is what makes it so
surprising first time visitors are
usually paranoid but once you get used
to it you know what you need to do to
stay safe stay inside after 10 p.m. to
avoid assaults don't use your phone in
public to make sure that no one will
want to steal it don't bring anything
but your bathing suit to the beach and
take the metro visiting Copacabana can
be awesome as long as you're cautious
the Hollywood sign this is one of the
most recognizable signs on earth and
also the first thing that people see
from the plane when they visit the city
but people who live near it don't like
it as much as tourists do that's why
some of them are trying to remove it
from google maps people who live near
the Hollywood sign are
tired of seeing tourists who are so
interested in nine letters on a hill
this is why some of them put fake signs
on the street to warn people that they
can't have access to the Hollywood sign
unfortunately they don't have the right
to block the streets so that doesn't
solve the problem but with technology
they found a new way to make sure that
tourists would stay as far from their
place as possible they just made the
sign invisible online so knowing can
find it anyway you can't really get that
close to the Hollywood sign first it's
in a park so you can't really drive
there and if you really want to get to
the sign you have to hike and even then
you will just end up above the sign so
it's much harder than what people
usually think the best way to see the
Hollywood sign is from afar because
that's why it was created Mexico in this
city you will find one of the best
examples of wealth and poverty that's
because you can live in the most
luxurious hotel while your next-door
neighbor is struggling to pay for food
photographer Johnny Miller took aerial
images from a helicopter to reveal the
extreme wealth inequalities between
neighborhoods that's because the rich
people and the poor are often just
separated by a wall or a highway here
you can see the beautiful houses with
the slums right next door then we have
the private school with the beautiful
tennis court and the misshapen football
pitch a few feet away from it you just
have to cross the street and you are
transported to a whole new world at
least two million people are living in
what most people call slums that's
because more than 40% of the population
is poor for a total of 122 million
people in the whole country and when it
comes to extreme poverty we are talking
about more than 7% of the population but
then they look up and they see
skyscrapers dominating the sky that's
what happens when only 1% of the
population is really wealthy with 16
billion airs in the country this is what
makes Mexico one of the most unequal
countries in the world even though it's
one of the 14 richest countries
Stonehenge you have all heard about
Stonehenge and it looks very impressive
when you look at the pictures that you
have already seen but
you take a step back in a helicopter
you'll notice that it's much smaller
than we thought it was it is just a
little circle in a big field next to a
road and when 1 million tourists visit
the place every year it is also hard to
make sure that no one stands in your
picture but no matter what you will
always be impressed when you think that
neolithic builders took 1500 years to
build it as it was built in several
stages and it all started 5,000 years
ago however historians don't really
understand how they found a way to place
these 100 massive upright stones in a
circle at that time the wheel wasn't
even invented so it was probably really
hard to move them it is simply
incredible when you think that these
rocks were originally found 200 miles
away from Stonehenge this is why many
historians had to think about different
theories to explain this the rocks could
have been transported up with sleds and
ropes it's also possible that they
fashioned sledges and rollers out of
tree trunks to lug the rocks on a long
distance no matter what asking so many
questions makes us want to see this
place even more Santorini when we think
of Greece all we can see is white
buildings and the blue water in case you
didn't know you were probably thinking
about the beautiful island of Santorini
however your pictures on Instagram might
look a little different than what you
expected that's because so many tourists
want to visit this place but it's all
you're going to see in your picture but
don't worry it's still a great place to
visit first you have to take a ferry
which can take around five hours you
have plenty of time to imagine the
beautiful things that you're going to
see in Santorini but you can also fly if
you're looking for something a little
faster some of the most interesting
things to do on the island are hiking
the caldera path taking a tour renting a
scooter or eating amazing food but what
we love the most is probably just taking
pictures and enjoying the view on this
beautiful island this is the best way to
capture this moment and make this
adventure last forever as long as people
are not skating in the way if you could
have a free ticket to visit one place in
the world where would you go don't be
shy to answer
comment section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for 10
photos that will change the way you see
the world for more stories like this
make sure you watch 10 amazing pictures
they won't show you in history books
thanks for watching
[Music]